- Good afternoon, everyone.
Glad to see so many of you here.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study,
and I'm so happy you
could be here to join us
for today's panel, entitled,
Hidden in Plain Sight, Family
Secrets and American History.
As Harvard's Institute
for Advanced Study,
Radcliffe has a dual mission.
We support cutting edge work
across the arts, the sciences,
the social sciences,
and the humanities,
and we share that work with
broad public audiences.
We offer a packed
calendar of events,
including lectures, conferences,
exhibitions, and panel
discussions like the one
we're about to hear today.
You can find more information
about all of our programming
on our website.
Now today, our
distinguished panelists
will share what they have
learned about uncovering
hidden family histories.
And I'm grateful to all
of them for joining us,
and I look forward
to their insights.
As we dive into this
fascinating topic,
I think we will see that rich
and revealing archives do not
only live in libraries,
but they can also
be found in basements,
closets, and attics.
Whether a diary, a letter,
a photograph, or a deed,
these documents
reveal truths that
matter for relatives
and for descendants,
but they also contribute to
our understanding of history
more broadly.
The unique window
into lived experience
that family artifacts can reveal
makes it all the more important
that some of them find their way
into manuscript repositories,
where they can be properly
preserved, cataloged, and made
available to researchers to
tell a more nuanced and complex
American history.
Radcliffe's Schlesinger
Library on the History
of Women in America, which
organized today's event,
is the preeminent
archive documenting
the history of women and
gender in this country,
and it houses an incredible
collection of these artifacts,
among many other
important materials.
Because libraries
like the Schlesinger
play such a crucial role
in facilitating the writing
and analyzing of
American history,
we are now particularly focused
on diversifying our collections
to make sure that they are
preserving a full spectrum
of women's experiences
across class, race,
political perspective,
sexual orientation,
religious experience, and more.
We have also prioritized
expanding access
to the library's
valuable resources
by digitizing its most
sought after collections.
We face other new
challenges, as we
seek to ensure that scholars
and students in the future
will have all the
evidence they need
to write responsible and
inclusive histories of today.
With so much of the human
record we produce nowadays
being ephemeral, whether
a text message, an email,
or a blog post, the
Schlesinger is actively
collecting and
preserving materials
that were created
electronically,
referred to as born
digital, whether
e-correspondence or
online magazines,
or any of the many
other ways that we
record private and
public interactions
in our contemporary culture.
Jane Kamensky, my colleague
in the History Department here
at Harvard, and the Karlen
Lily Pforzheimer Foundation
director of the
Schlesinger Library
has been leading these
efforts, with the help
of her partner,
Marilyn Dunn, who
is the executive director
of the Schlesinger,
and their expert staff.
Jane is an historian of early
America, the Atlantic World,
and the Age of Revolutions,
with a particular interest
in the history of families.
And I want to thank
Jane and her team
for organizing today's event.
And in just a moment
I will invite Jane up
to introduce our panelists
and our moderator.
But first let me tell you
how things will work today.
After the panel
discussion, we will open
the floor for your questions.
We'll be placing a microphone
in the center aisle.
We invite you to come up,
introduce yourself first.
That's important for us
all to know who's speaking.
Ask your question.
And then the next
person will have a turn.
After the Q&A, I invite you
all to join us next door
for a reception in the
Sheerr Room of Fay House.
Now please extend a warm
welcome to Jane Kamensky.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon, everybody,
and welcome on behalf
of the Schlesinger Library,
about which Liz just
said such very nice things.
When we sponsor events, we try
to keep several goals in view.
We embody Radcliffe's commitment
to bring cutting edge thinking
to the public, and to
advance the work of scholars,
exploring topics related to
women, gender, and sexuality.
We also use events
like this to expose
our collections and the
kinds of work they do,
and to build relationships
with people whose papers we
hope to collect in future.
And today's panel discussion,
Hidden in Plain Sight,
or HIPS, as the staff
has taken to calling it,
does all of these things.
The conversation
that brings together
these four amazing panelists
under the direction
of our gifted moderator
has a high concept premise,
and I wanted to take a
few moments to describe it
before introducing our guests.
So Hidden in Plain Sight borrows
the title of a wonderful book
by the Rutgers
University sociologist,
Eviatar Zerubavel--
a study of what Zerubavel
calls, the social structure
of irrelevance.
He's interested in
what gets noticed,
what counts as figure
in art history terms,
and what gets reduced
to field or background.
He writes that
nothing is inherently
figure-like or background-like.
Instead, we make judgments
about what gets seen
and what stays hidden.
And the book's cover features
the work-- a different image--
but the work of this
artist, Liu Bolin, whose art
plays with exactly this issue.
So this slide is
Liu's Instillation,
Hiding in The City Number 110.
And though the artist is
standing right in front of us,
we have to really be
looking for him to see him.
We're conditioned to see the
detritus of consumer society,
this work argues,
and that conditioning
makes it increasingly
impossible for us
to see human relationships.
In other words, for Liu
and for the sociologist,
Zerah Bible, what
hides in plain sight
shows us a lot about who
we are and how we think.
Our panelist Alice Echols
notes that psychologists
have another word for
this unknown knowledge--
those half-seen truths that
haunt most American families--
nescience, they call it.
That feeling just
short of consciousness.
And so to American families,
a core, as Liz said,
of Schlesinger
Library collections.
All of us have family secrets--
issues big and small, that hide
in plain sight in our families,
known but unseen,
or seen but unknown.
Collections of family papers
are full of nescience.
Most times these
have no importance
beyond the family circle.
Like, for example, the fact that
my paternal grandmother claimed
on her marriage license
to have wed at 17,
but was shown on her birth
certificate to be only 14.
This is true.
And this was
secret, but it's not
a secret that opens a new
vista onto American history.
The family truths our panelists
hold to the light in the four
projects they're
discussing this afternoon
are of a different order.
Big questions in American
and even in global history
determine what truths
needed to be hidden
by members of the Calhoun and
Faludi and Davis and Wagner
families--
what could be seen and
what stories would be told?
The ways their families
organized field and background
in turn shaped the
broader history
of the 19th and 20th centuries.
Before turning the
panel over, I'll
introduce the panelists in
the order they'll speak,
which is alphabetically
by last name,
and say way too little about
each of their projects.
First up will be author
Gail Lumet Buckley,
whose three books all
center, to some degree,
on a trunk of papers kept by
her grandfather, Teddy Horne,
and passed down
through the family,
including his famous daughter,
Gail's mother, the actor
and musical icon, Lena Horne.
Gail, who was an honors
graduate of Radcliffe College
and a journalist,
is also a biographer
who has published in the Los
Angeles Times, the Washington
Post, Vogue, Playboy,
and People, among others.
And she has reckoned
with that family legacy
through much of
her writing life.
Her first two books, The
Hornes: An American Family,
and American Patriots:
The Story of Blacks
in the Military from
the Revolution to Desert
Storm spring in parts directly
from Teddy Hornes' trunk.
She'll talk today about her
most recent book, The Black
Calhouns, which takes
her storied family back
into the days of slavery
and reconstruction,
where their history braided with
the family of John C. Calhoun
and his brother, Andrew.
The black Calhouns were
oppressed, but not hidden,
Buckley emphasized when
the panels spoke by phone
a couple of weeks ago.
Their lives were entwined
with the broadest outlines
of American history,
including slavery, war,
and the long Civil
Rights Movement--
institutions and
events and movements
that they shaped in turn.
Speaking second is Alice Echols,
who holds the Barbara Streisand
Chair of Contemporary
Gender Studies
and is also professor of history
at the University of Southern
California.
Echols is one of the foremost
historians of American culture
in the post-war era.
Her books include,
the field-defining,
Daring to be Bad: Radical
Feminism in America, 1967
to '75, which followed
the lives and thought
of many of the activists
whose papers eventually landed
at the Schlesinger.
But Echols wrote about
them before their archives
were anywhere, preceding
largely by interview
to map a story that nobody
else had managed to recover,
much less make sense of.
Her subsequent
books, each of which
has won various
forms of acclaim,
include, Scars of
Sweet Paradise,
a biography of Janis
Joplin, and Hot Stuff:
Disco and the Remaking
of American Culture.
Shortfall, the project about
which she'll talk today
is in many ways a
departure for her.
It's a family history,
centering on the life and times
of her grandfather, a
savings and loan founder
who was, she explains, the
very opposite of Frank Capra's
beloved George Bailey.
Echol's family wrapped
Davis, her mother's father,
in silence.
When she began to
note that absence
and dig for what was
hidden in plain sight,
she stumbled on
a treasure trove,
not so unlike Teddy Hornes'
trunk, and also in the attic,
some 70 boxes of papers
stashed in her childhood home.
As she sifted the
contents of those boxes
and continued the
sleuthing beyond them,
she recovered not only the
predatory lending and fraud
at the heart of her
grandfather's rise and fall,
but a fresh picture of
an era of boom and bust
and hollow gilded
fortunes, built
on the backs of ordinary
people, chasing their slices
of American home ownership.
Susan Faludi's family
secret went hunting for her,
rather than the
other way around.
In the summer of
2004, her father,
from whom she had been distant
for more than two decades,
sent her an email with
the subject line, Changes.
Stephen Faludi had been reborn
following gender transition
surgery as Stephanie.
The revelation was shocking,
but not entirely surprising,
in that throughout
her childhood,
Faludi had experienced
her father as remote,
somehow invisible, she writes.
He seemed permanently
undercover.
Stephanie's gender
transition made
her visible to her
daughter, but it's only
in the course of Faludi's
marvelous excursion
into family and global history
that Stephanie becomes legible.
As a Jewish boy amidst the
trauma of central Europe
under the shadow
of the Holocaust,
as a volatile and unhappy man
amidst the gendered prison
of post-war American
suburbia, and finally
as an exuberant yet
not quite reliable
narrator in the
topsy turvy world
of post-communist Hungary.
Faludi, who's pioneering
long form journalism probed
the fruits of
feminism in Backlash:
The Undeclared War
Against American Women,
and the perils of modern
masculinity in Stiffed:
The Betrayal of American Men,
creates in, In the Dark Room,
an intimate epic of
identity and history, which
was a finalist for the
2016 Pulitzer Prize,
winner of the Kirkus Prize, and
one of the New York Times Book
reviews top 10 books last
year, and deservedly so.
Finally, Alex
Wagner will give us
a preview of her first book,
Futureface, a family mystery,
an epic quest, and a
search for belonging,
which will be out next fall
from Random House's One World
Imprint.
Wagner will be
familiar to many of you
as a print, radio, and
television journalist.
Currently she appears as
a CBS News correspondent
and as the co-host of CBS
This Morning Saturday.
Before joining CBS, Wagner was
a senior editor at The Atlantic,
where her beat included
politics, culture,
and social trends, and where
she remains as a contributing
editor.
In her journalism and
in her advocacy work
against mass atrocities,
she had traveled
to various global
hotspots, including Burma,
whence her mother emigrated
to the United States.
The entwining of her
mother's and father's
families, and the
idea of bloodlines
as story and destiny, is
the subject of Futureface.
The title comes from a
Time Magazine article,
"the New Face of America," which
a very young Alex read in 1993.
The computer generated composite
face, a post-racial hybrid,
looked like her, she noticed,
as a sophomore in high school.
In the course of
analyzing her membership
in what she calls, the
polyglot tribe of all,
Wagner explores the stories
Americans tell themselves
about themselves--
stories of immigration
and integration
about who are our
people and what
makes them so, as she puts it.
Her journey into
Wagner family stories,
what she calls her
ancestor quest,
uncovers a variety
of embellishments,
suppressions, and outright lies.
When she finds, as she writes,
a snag in the carefully
woven story on either side of
her family tree, she pulls it.
Doing so, she delves, not only
into her own family history,
but also into the nature of
the need to know who we are--
a search for identity that has
become as American as apple
pie, cutting across, as
Wagner writes, both red state
American exceptionalism and
blue state ethnic transcendence.
After Buckley, Echols,
Faludi, and Wagner
each introduce their
projects, Annette Gordon-Reed
will facilitate a
conversation across the panel.
Gordon Reed, a Radcliffe
Institute Professor,
the Charles Warren Professor
of American Legal History--
hang on, cause she's
got a lot of titles--
at Harvard Law School, and
my colleague in the Harvard
History Department has won too
many honors and awards for me
to begin to name them here.
As a scholar over many books of
the relationship between Thomas
Jefferson and Sally Hemings,
and the impacts both
the white and black Jeffersons
have had on US history,
she investigates
the relationship
between black slavery
and white liberty, which
is arguably the
primal family secret
in all of American history.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
We will proceed in
alphabetical order.
Everyone will take about
eight minutes, give or take.
And then we will have
questions-- well actually,
we will have questions
from me, and then
we will have questions from you.
And please remember
to identify yourself
before you ask the questions.
So we will start with Gail.
Hello.
Before I start, I need to give
two sentimental disclosures.
The only A I ever got at Harvard
was from professor Schlesinger.
[LAUGHING]
And he later on married one
of my best Radcliffe friends.
So I'm doubly honored
and happy to be here,
in support of the Radcliffe
Institute and the Schlesinger
Library.
Thank you.
When I was growing up
in the 1940s and '50s,
African-Americans had not
yet discovered Africa.
Nor, more important, had they
discovered their true role
in American history.
They lived in a sort
of historical limbo,
because both histories were
too terrible to contemplate.
On the one hand, the slave
trade, on the other hand,
slavery itself.
From a sense of guilt, and a
wish to avoid the awful truth,
white America, in the
south in particular,
perpetuated the myth
of the happy slave.
Most Negroes, as
African-Americans
were then called, refused to
believe that the happy slave
ever existed.
What I discovered through
the black Calhouns however,
was that while there may not
have been many happy slaves,
there were, hidden in plain
sight, some lucky slaves.
As slavery went, the black
Calhouns' extended family
who centuries long story
I tell, from 1865 to 1964,
South and North, were
not exactly happy,
but they were certainly lucky.
They were an intact family.
They could read and write.
They'd been house slaves.
They had lived in a town,
not on a plantation,
and they had a rich and
quasi-benevolent owner.
They also benefited from a
secret, hidden in plain sight.
The photographs-- there's
a photograph of Moses,
yes, my great-great-grandfather,
taken some 20 years
after the war, about the
time that the Atlanta
Constitution called him,
the wealthiest colored
man in Atlanta.
And my great-grandparents--
Moses' eldest
daughter, Cora, aged
22 at the time of
her 1887 marriage
to Edwin Horne, who was
born free in Indiana.
Moses was lucky because his
owner, Dr. Andrew Bonaparte
Calhoun, important enough
to need a literate butler
had him educated, despite
laws to the contrary.
Dr. Calhoun, part owner of
Georgia's only gold mine,
and the first man to sign
George's Article of Secession,
was a cousin of John C.
Calhoun, arch white supremacist
and slavery's most
famous apologist.
The black Calhouns had a
sort of family business
with the white Calhouns.
Moses was the Butler.
His mother was the cook, and his
sister, something of a beauty,
with the nursemaid.
And Calhoun was a
benevolent owner.
In 1870 he deeded
an acre of land
to Moses' mother and sister.
And therein lies a
typical antebellum secret.
The black Calhouns and the white
Calhouns are probably related.
No one knows for sure,
but the white Calhouns,
who I met in Atlanta
on my book tour,
believed it was true,
because the gift of land
was extraordinary for someone
who was merely a slave.
Moses waited until
he was free to marry.
In 1865, at the
age of 36, he found
a wife, who was 15 years
younger, came from New Orleans,
had always been free,
and looked white.
They had two beautiful
daughters, Cora and Lena.
Possibly helped by Dr. Calhoun,
Moses opened a grocery store
and catering establishment.
He later opened a
small boarding house.
Because he was educated, Moses
had a leg up in peace time.
More important,
war-torn Atlanta now
presented level playing
fields for whites
and some lucky blacks.
No one, white or black,
had much of anything.
Along with equality
of condition,
there was a new equality of law.
The new miracle
of Reconstruction
was made for Moses.
He registered as a
Republican voter,
opened an account in the
Freedman's Savings Bank,
whose last CEO was
Frederick Douglass,
and became a pillar of the
first Congregational Church.
He now saw that his
daughters were educated.
So-called missionary schools,
today's historically black
colleges, were created
throughout the old Confederacy
to train the first black
teachers in the south
after a century or more
of enforced illiteracy.
The modern Civil Rights Movement
began in these 19th century
schools, established by
northern white philanthropists,
and staffed by northern white
who instilled confidence
as well as rigorous academics
into young people who
have been told for so long
that they were inferior beings,
and now were told
exactly the opposite.
Atlanta had two important
missionary schools--
the Storrs School
for younger children,
and Atlanta University,
the Storrs' graduates.
The head of both schools was
a young Yale Divinity School
graduate named Asa
Ware who became
an abolitionist at the age of
15 after reading, Uncle Tom's
Cabin.
When asked how he could
live among blacks,
Ware explained that it was
easy because he was colorblind.
According to the Atlanta
Constitution in 1871,
the Storrs School [INAUDIBLE]
the extremely color-conscious
citizens of Atlanta.
To see colored boys and girls
reading in Greek and Latin,
and demonstrating
correctly, problems
in algebra and geometry,
and seemingly understanding
what they demonstrated,
appears almost wonderful.
When Ware died, age 48, after
20 years at Storrs in Atlanta,
his will stipulated that he
be buried in a black cemetery.
The city of Atlanta
denied his wish,
but compromised by
allowing him to be buried
in the middle of the
road that divided
the black and white
section of the cemetery.
Cora Calhoun had
attended Atlanta,
but her younger
sister Lena left home
for another missionary college,
Fisk, in Nashville, Tennessee,
named for a Union general.
Lena's 17-year-old
classmate, Willie Du Bois
of Great Barrington,
Massachusetts,
whose family had lived
free in the Berkshires
since colonial times,
fell hopelessly in love
with her, as W.E.B.
Du Bois later
wrote about the rosy apricot
beauty of Lena Calhoun.
Willie Du Bois had
been an all-around star
at Great Barrington
high school, where
the only other black
students were his cousins.
He had already been
accepted at Harvard,
but Harvard sent him to Fisk
for academic acclamation.
Du Bois later said that he was
happy with Harvard's decision.
If he had gone to
Harvard first, he said,
he might have tried to make
friends with white students,
and been hurt by their rebuffs.
He'd experienced no racism
in Great Barrington.
But after Fisk, he wrote, "a
new loyalty and allegiance
replaced my Americanism.
Henceforth I was a Negro."
Du Bois also gave the name
to his fellow missionary
schoolteachers to be, calling
them the talented 10th--
the 10% of the Negro
race, who were expected
to uplift the other 90%.
Edwin Horne, Cora
Calhoun's husband
became a success, partly
because of another secret
in plain sight.
His father was a
white Englishman,
and his mother was
a Native American.
Edwin chose to call
himself colored,
because in Indiana, whose
wartime governor was
an ardent abolitionist, it was
better to be black than Indian.
As a young colored
man, he stood out
as a teacher and
journalist, writing
for both the white and black
Evansville, Indiana papers.
In 1875, the white
Evansville journal reported,
"at the close of the
written examination
of the second
intermediate schools,
it was discovered that
the pupils of the colored
school of that grade,
taught by Edwin F. Horne,
had the highest general
average in the city."
In 1881, Jim Crow, named for
an 1830's era minstrel song
was officially
born in Tennessee,
the birthplace of the KKK.
It was soon spread throughout
the south, the border states,
and much of the north.
In 1883, Senator Charles
Sumner's great Civil Rights Act
of 1875, a cornerstone
of Reconstruction,
was declared unconstitutional.
Black despair followed.
By 1896, when the Supreme Court
decision, Plessy v. Ferguson
entrenched separate but
equal, Cora and Edwin Horne
had moved to New York.
They would have four sons, two
born in the south and two born
in the north, were Edwin, the
former colored Republican, now
known as the Adonis
of the Negro press,
became a Democrat
and a Tammany man.
As an active member of
black Tammany in 1910,
Edwin ran for the
New York City Council
and lost on the Tammany ticket.
But Tammany rewarded him for
writing The 1910 pamphlet that
swayed the black
males in New York
to elect a Democrat as
governor for the first time
since the Civil War.
1910 in New York saw
the black peril menace,
in which blacks
were not permitted
to appear on Broadway,
although Bert
Williams, a black
superstar, was allowed
to appear in the
Ziegfeld Follies,
or to attend any midtown
theater or restaurant.
In 1912, the NAACP
successfully sued the city
to overthrow the
edict, which is clearly
more southern than northern.
That same year, an editorial in
the Raleigh News and Observer
succinctly explained
the southern position.
"This objection of
the Negro politically
and the separation of
the Negro socially,
are paramount to all
considerations in the south,
short of the preservation
of the republic itself.
Meanwhile, the family of
Moses Calhoun's sister
has stayed in the
south to become
pillars of black
Atlanta society,
and leaders of the community.
As principal of a black
school, Catherine's husband
was fired, refusing to let
his pupils march in a mandated
parade of
schoolchildren to honor
the remains of Jefferson Davis,
as they passed through Atlanta.
But he had the
last laugh when he
became the first black licensed
real estate broker in Atlanta,
and a very wealthy man.
He had four daughters
and one son.
His youngest daughter
married a young captain
in a World War I
Medical Corps, who
became the father and
grandfather of doctors,
and when he died was
the longest practicing
black doctor in Georgia,
and the longest practicing
doctor of any race in Atlanta.
In the north, Cora Horne
remained Republican.
Influenced by
Tammany, however, she
made a quasi-death
bed conversion
from congregationalism
to Catholicism,
when she was pregnant
with her fourth son,
and named him for the
priest who converted her.
Cora was a spiritual
seeker, and in her lifetime
journeyed from
Congregationalism to Catholicism
to ethical culture
and finally to Bahai.
After her fourth child, Cora
discovered another secret.
Edwin had a white
mistress in Manhattan,
who shared his nightlife,
while Cora and the boys
were at home in Brooklyn.
Cora's revenge was to refuse
to speak to Edwin from then on.
They communicated via notes
passed by their youngest son,
and to throw herself
into activism.
At the time of her
death, Cora was
listed as having been an
active member or board
member of the following
organizations--
the YWCA, the Red Cross, the
Mayor's World War Victory
Committee, the NAACP, Urban
League, the Big Brother
and Big Sister
Organizations, where
she mentored young Paul
Robeson, the Brooklyn
Bureau of Charities, the
National Association of Colored
Women, the Brooklyn Urban
League, the New York
branch of the Women's
International League of Peace,
the Foreign Policy Association
of the International
Council of Women of
the Darker Races,
founded in 1922 by
Women Corps among them,
from the US, Africa, Haiti,
the West Indies, and Ceylon.
In addition, she was
corresponding secretary
of the Eastern Division of the
National Republican Women's
Auxiliary, and on the
National Speaker's Bureau
of the Republican Party.
Introducing activism
to the family in 1919,
she enrolled her granddaughter,
my mother, Lena Horne,
as a lifetime member of the
NAACP at the age of two.
[LAUGHING]
I began this project
when my mother died,
and I found family papers
of the southern side
of the family, collected
by my Atlanta-based library
genealogist cousin,
Catherine Nash Harris, who
did all the hard work.
I had the fun job of
putting the family
into historical perfection
and hunting down gossip.
Hidden in plain
sight in Atlanta was
a world I never knew existed.
A business culture rather than
a planter culture, Atlanta
never punished black
financial success.
Although politically
and socially oppressed,
Atlanta's black middle
class nevertheless
led happy and successful
lives by looking
inward to family, business,
schools, clubs, and church.
Their northern counterparts
clearly had more choices,
but also more failed marriages,
more adultery, more alcoholism,
et cetera.
The success, wealth, and
for want of a better term,
mental health at the
Atlanta black middle class
was both a secret and a
very pleasant surprise.
Du Bois wrote that the
problem of the 20th century
was a problem of the color line.
Clearly it will continue to be
a problem in the 21st century.
But the story of the 20th
century black middle class
has lessons to teach about
fortitude and perseverance,
in the secret corners of
race, sex and politics.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
I am here to talk
about this book.
It's just out on the New Press.
It's called, Shortfall:
Family Secrets.
It's a huge subtitle,
probably inadvisedly so--
Family Secrets,
Financial Collapse,
and a Hidden History of
American Banking This
is a book that exposes secret
histories of my family,
of the place they were from,
Colorado Springs, Colorado,
and of American capitalism.
Hidden in plain sight describes
all too well the secrets
that I write about.
The very first
bits of my archive
emerge actually not from
those boxes in the attic,
although those certainly
featured later in it,
but from a very beautiful
but very battered
Louis Vuitton trunk, that
sat in my family's rec room,
closed but unlocked,
for nearly 50 years.
And I used to spend tons
of time in that rec room,
and I never opened it.
Ah.
And when it comes to
the financial history
that I chronicle here,
which is the cratering
of our country's
building and loan
industry-- a very important
industry, by the way,
during the depression-- that
too was hiding in plain sight.
One can find mention of it and
the fraud that sometimes caused
the failure of individual
building and loans or BNLs
as I will be calling them here.
Indeed, I found, I think,
the very first reference
to such failures in Elizabeth
Cohen's, Making a New Deal.
But the secondary literature
on the thrift industry
generally boasts of its
remarkable resilience,
in fact its goodness
during these years.
One scholar calls them,
banks with a soul.
And the idea that fraud was in
any way associated with them
really seems unthinkable
in these texts.
Now Shortfall uses the failure
of the BNL industry, a history
it tells in microcosm through
the firestorm that enveloped
Colorado Springs,
in order to think
about the relationship between
property, class, and politics
in America, and with, I
think a lot of relevance
to today's America.
You could say that
the book exposes
the underbelly of
American capitalism,
as I sometimes have, but
that suggests something
more discreet, more delimited
than the bloated underbelly
I discovered.
I often wondered, as I
researched this history,
that it really I think captures
quite nicely, the space where
dreams and scams commingled.
Where does the underbelly end?
And I can tell you, it extended
all the way to Main Street.
And this is not the
way I know that it's
meant to be in America.
In America, Main Street
exists as a kind of refuge
from bad capitalism.
Case in point go back to
the Democratic primaries
and the ways in which Sanders
and Clinton would answer
questions about capitalism.
Now it's this fairy tale version
of Main Street capitalism
as a site of honesty,
transparency, and fairness that
animates Frank Capra's 1946
film, It's a Wonderful Life.
And, you know, this is an
iconic image from that movie.
How many of you have
seen this movie?
OK.
Many, many, many.
All through the 70s and
80s because it fell out
of copyright.
And here, this is an image in
which the selfless BNL operator
George Bailey,
beleaguered as well,
and his long suffering, even
more beleaguered wife, Mary,
are putting an end
to a bank run that's
been engineered by the
town's fat cat banker,
by distributing their
very own honeymoon money.
But here we have another couple.
This is Walter and
Lula Davis, and they
were my maternal grandparents.
And I think it's fair to say
that my grandparents would not
have distributed their honeymoon
money to distressed depositors.
[LAUGHING]
Even to stop a bank run.
Walter Davis became briefly
famous across the country
as a bankster, as in gangster.
It was a fairly
typical nomenclature
in the Depression years
when the banksters
were really reviled and hated.
He went on the lam in 1932,
just before the authorities
discovered that his
building and loan had
suffered a shocking
$1.25 million shortfall.
That's nearly $22 million
in today's dollars.
Now, one big challenge in
writing this book for me--
and there were many--
was figuring out what
made these people tick.
That meant grappling with
the class consciousness
of my maternal grandmother, a
young woman looking for any way
to escape where
she had come from,
a sodden, tubercular
hollow, where she lived
with her parents and older--
I know it's a bit over--
[LAUGHING]
And older brothers, all of
them working backbreaking jobs,
which was true.
And all of them--
I mean, when I discovered this,
it was quite a discovery--
all of them dead by
the time she was 10.
She was orphaned
at the age of 10.
And you know, you
look at this woman
and you wouldn't think
that that was her past.
And also I wanted to
understand the consciousness
of my grandfather, a
son of a barber who
hoped he could reinvent
himself as a lawyer in Colorado
Springs-- even printed up
cards that called himself
a lawyer, when he moved, to have
them on the ready when he moved
to Colorado, and
ended up a loan shark,
before successfully deploying
that particular business
model in the BNL industry.
And then also my mother,
who at the end of her life
described her family to me as
nobodies, come from nowhere.
And she included
herself in that.
And she also said,
not from good stock.
That was the phrase used.
So for me, class,
how it works on us,
how we work it, as
we push its levers,
to paraphrase Barbara
and Karen Fields,
that's the kind of
spine of the book.
And in a certain way,
one of the reasons
that I was interested in
doing this kind of a book
and in exploring this kind
of class consciousness
is that I'd been
very affected by some
of the scholarship of the
British working classes
that one might associate
with Caroline Steedman, Seth
Koven, and others.
And it's a kind of
class consciousness
that US historians,
particularly of the '30s,
haven't lingered on,
shall we say, because
of the preferences for
heroic collectivist,
solidarity forever kind
of class consciousness.
Now Shortfall is
a braided history.
And its most central
braid is the BNL industry.
As I said, this was an
industry that was once really
a key important part of
America's financial landscape.
It was a vehicle--
it was meant to be-- for
working class home ownership.
These BNLs were originally
known as poor man's banks.
But by the '20s they
were increasingly
being taken over by unscrupulous
characters like my grandfather.
And the consequences ultimately
when the Depression hit
were really quite calamitous.
And I spent a lot of time in
the book documenting this.
Now property looms very
large in Shortfall.
And I think my book reveals,
as does the subprime mortgage
crisis in the Great Recession
of our own time, that owning
property can in fact be one's
undoing as well as ones making.
Certainly for the
working classes,
home ownership became a
much riskier proposition
with this new BNL
business model.
Something else may
have happened as well,
which is that I think--
and I go out on a
limb a bit here--
buying a house
was, I think, less
likely to be a community
endeavor supported
by one's neighbors, as it
had been when BNLs were part
of the fabric of the country's
co-operative movement
in the 19th century.
And it became much more of
an individual achievement,
and one that in
certain circumstances
may have oriented homeowners
politically to the right.
This shift may
help explain how it
is that so many ordinary
Americans, including Americans
of the white working classes
came to embrace self-reliance,
which I think over time
became racially coded,
and to look skeptically
upon government
programs as a solution
to social problems.
I found this in
Colorado Springs.
When BNL depositors, pissed
off about being defrauded,
organized.
But they organized in
a very interesting way.
They were led by leaders of a
local tax limitation movement.
And the similarities
that I discovered
between the taxpayers
associations of the Great
Depression-- and these
are very under-studied.
They're worthy of
much more study--
and the Tea Party of
our own Great Recession.
It was really quite striking.
A tax on government and its
bureaucrats for subsidizing,
"losers," antipathy
to regulation, faith
and self-reliance
and free enterprise,
and the politics of
aggrievement that really
fueled both of these movements.
Over the past year,
people have puzzled over
why even ordinary Americans
are so tax averse,
and why conservatism
appeals to some
among the white working classes.
I'll tell you, this
doesn't surprise me
because I've spent a long
time now studying what
happened in the '20s and '30s.
And let's just say this has
been a long time in the making.
Ultimately,
Shortfall asks why it
is that we are so forgiving of
capitalism, and so unforgiving
of those who fall
behind, or who,
by virtue of
systemic inequality,
have always been behind.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much.
It's really great to
be back at Radcliffe,
and to be a part of this
incredible group of writers.
I actually started writing this
book here, kind of on the QT,
while I was on a
Radcliffe fellowship.
I was supposed to be
working on something else.
But that's how it
works at Radcliffe.
So to be invited back
to talk about it,
feels like a sentimental return.
This is a book I
couldn't not write.
It's about a part of my
life that was, indeed,
hidden in plain
sight, even for me,
Which is why I had to write it.
I couldn't go forward honestly
with my public feminism
without coming to grips with
this event in my private life.
But writing it also helped me
grapple with some big questions
about gender and
identity that are
roiling in our current
political landscape.
So in my eight minutes,
I want to tell you first
about my father's
transformation and how
that played out for her and in
our complicated relationship.
But I also want to touch
on a larger political drama
that was going on in the time
I was visiting my father,
which is highly
relevant, unfortunately,
to the present moment
in this country.
So as Jane pointed out, I
was sitting at home in 2004,
minding my own business.
Actually I was sorting
through notes on my last book
about the masculinity
crisis, when I received
this email from my father.
And it began, "Dear,
Susan, I've got
some interesting news for you.
I have decided that
I have had enough
of impersonating a macho
aggressive man that I've never
been inside."
Well this interesting
news, illustrated
with several
attached selfies, was
that my father, without
telling anyone in the family,
had flown all alone to Thailand
to have gender reassignment
surgery.
To make matters
more complicated,
my father at the time
was 76-years-old,
and we had been estranged.
My father and I
had barely spoken
in more than a quarter century.
That was because when
I was growing up,
my father was indeed a,
"macho aggressive" man, also
autocratic, domineering,
bullying, and violent,
all of which fueled
my early feminism.
Well, a couple of
months after that email,
and at the invitation of my
father to write about her,
I got on a plane
to Hungary, which
was where my father was
living, because in 1990,
my father had returned to the
country where she had grown up.
And by the way, if
you're wondering
why I'm saying my father
instead of my parent,
it's because that's
what she wanted.
I'm still your father, you
know, she liked to say to me.
Well, that first visit was a
real life test of my feminism.
And believe me, the ironies
were not lost on me.
You know, here is my father
whose patriarchal belligerence
really sparked my
feminist fervor,
who was going on about
Maybelline lip gloss,
giving me the grand tour of
her Marilyn Monroe wardrobe,
and singing the
praises of housewifery.
"You write about the
disadvantages of being a woman,
she told me, but I've
only found advantages."
And yet, as she
settled into herself,
she dropped the caricature
persona of vavoom vamp
and hausfrau, and
over time she became
more comfortable
with who she was,
which was a person much
more complex and interesting
than the cardboard cutout that
she had originally promoted.
Which is one reason
why I love this photo.
It's from 2010, and of the
two of us on the old siklo.
It was this cute
little incline train
that goes up to the top
of Castle Hill, which
my father had many
happy memories
about this little train.
But because she-- as you
can see, she's just--
she's not wearing any
of the fancy stuff,
and is just comfortable
with herself.
And I also came
to see, over time,
how she and I, in many ways,
were on a similar path, each
struggling to free ourselves
from the constraints of gender.
So in the end, my
father's transformation
affirmed my bedrock
feminist belief
that gender is
infinitely varied,
that we are all much
more than the sex roles
that society imposes on us.
My father wanted me to chronicle
only her new gender identity.
Anything from the past she
dismissed as, "irrelevant"
and, quote, "ancient history."
But her gender life was
inextricably tied to her past,
and in particular to her
religious and political
past experience.
My father grew up Istvan
Friedman, an only child
of wealthy Jewish
parents in Budapest,
and lived a life of
privilege until World War
II, when large
numbers of our family
would perish in the Holocaust.
And this is a photo of my great
grandparent's 50th wedding
anniversary in 1943,
their Golden Jubilee.
Six months later, all but three
of the people in this picture
were murdered.
My teenage father
survived-- by the way,
my father is right
there on the top row.
My father survived as
an urchin on the streets
in Budapest, passing
as a Christian
with false identity papers
and a stolen fascist armband.
One time my father
used that armband
to impersonate a Hungarian
Nazi Arrow Cross office,
so as to rescue my grandparents
from a, quote unquote,
protected house, whose residents
were about to be taken down
to the Danube and shot
into the river, which
was a fate for thousands
of Budapest's Jews
in the winter of 1944.
After the war, my father
went on to other identity
reinventions--
swashbuckling filmmaker
in the Brazilian outback,
alpine mountaineer an ice
climber, All-American commuter
dad in Westchester County,
and high-end commercial
photographer in Manhattan, whose
specialty was altering images.
People often see identity
as singular and stable.
But what I saw with my
father was an identity
that was multiple and fluid,
and had many threads that
were tangled in her mind.
As much as she
tried to seal away
the past, when she talked
to me about her gender
transformation, she
inevitably would
return to her Holocaust trauma.
Now, as I visited my father,
I found myself caught up
in another identity drama.
Hungary was undergoing
its own identity crisis,
one that would lead it to the
brink of a neo-fascist state.
I first encountered that crisis
when I was nearly mowed down
on the street in Budapest
by a militia of men
in black uniforms with
four red on white stripes.
This was the Magyar
Guard, which was then
the paramilitary wing of the
far right Jobbik Party, which
was openly advocating throwing
Jews out of the country
and rounding up Roma in, quote
unquote, detention camps.
The militiamen would go on to
terrorize Roma communities,
beat up Jewish worshippers, and
desecrate Holocaust memorials.
That four-stripe
insignia, by the way,
is a near replica of the 1940s
Hungarian Nazi Arrow Cross
insignia.
Well two years after
that encounter,
the rightest Fidesz Party swept
into power in 2010 elections,
by showcasing this confabulated
Magyar identity of martyred
and chest-beating nationalism--
a sort of, Make Hungary
Great Again campaign.
The new government quickly
undermined the independence
of the courts, the central
bank, and the media.
It rewrote the Constitution
to curtail civil liberties
and declare Hungary
a Christian nation.
And, oh yeah, built
a razor wire wall
along Hungary's southern
border to keep out refugees.
Let me just end with this
quick thought that part of what
my book explores is
the Janus-faced nature
of identity--
the way that identity
can be either liberating,
as with LGBT rights, civil
rights, or feminism, or it
can be nationalistic
and xenophobic.
The first identity search seeks
self-awareness, understanding,
self-discovery.
The second is an attempt to
paper over painful realities
by retreating into a fantasy
identity based on scapegoating,
self-pity, and the embrace of
an authoritarian strongman,
all of which probably
sounds pretty familiar.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- In the interest
of time, I'm going
to try and keep this succinct
SO we can get to the discussion.
And I'm going to stay
right here to do that.
OK.
If I could get the
first slide up.
I'm Alex Wagner.
I am the only child of a
Burmese-American union that
began, and for that matter ended
in Washington D.C. Growing up,
I was acutely aware of my
mother's family history.
This is my mother and
my grandmother in 1964,
on their way to America,
leaving Burma for the last time.
And my mom is the one
obviously on the left,
trying to do her best
Jackie Kennedy impression.
I was told growing up, a series
of incredibly romantic stories
about life in Burma,
that our family had lived
this incredibly cosmopolitan
life, that everyone was well
educated, that we had one of
the first Dodge motor cars
in Rangoon, that my
great aunts were educated
in university, which was
a fairly progressive thing
in 1930s Burma.
There were constant references
to leaders in Africa
or great works of English
literature or exotic foodstuffs
that you wouldn't normally
find in a Burmese household.
This was all evidence
of how special we were.
And I grew up
believing all of it.
My mother and my uncle
and my grandmother
fled the country in the early
1960s to come to America,
and I'm told they
never looked back.
My grandmother worked at
the Library of Congress
in the East Asian
Books Department.
My grandfather adapted
frighteningly quickly
to suburban American
life and ate chard steaks
and worked on his car
and became an American,
for all intents and purposes.
My mother, who was college-aged,
went to Swarthmore,
where she got a full
scholarship and became enamored
of left wing politics as one
would in the 1960s and '70s,
and eventually moved
to Washington D.C.,
where she met my father.
They were both
organizing labor unions,
as one did in the late 1960s
and '70s in Washington D.C.
In many ways my mother's story
was the quintessential story
of 20th century
migration-- men and women
fleeing political
persecution, coming
to America to seek freedom.
On the other side
was my dad's family.
That's my dad, the smaller
of the two brothers.
He grew up in Northeastern
Iowa in a tiny town
on the Mississippi River
called Lansing, Iowa.
And in many ways, his story
was the quintessential story
of late 19th
century immigration.
His people had come
from western Europe,
seeking greater or at
least better fortunes
here in the West.
His grandfather, a man named
Henry Wagner, or at least
we thought his name was Henry
Wagner, but more on that
later--
he moved here from the tiny
town of Esch-Sur-Alzette
in Luxembourg.
I had no idea where that was,
and I didn't particularly
care growing up.
I just knew it was cool to
have ancestors from Luxembourg.
They somehow ended
up in Lansing,
and he became the proprietor
of a local saloon and grocery,
and had 14 children--
a Catholic boy done good.
These were the divergent
branches of my family tree,
and I was raised with them
in the back of my mind.
They were pleasant
boughs to hang from,
but not much more than that.
And if anybody asked,
I couldn't tell anybody
more than the general outlines
that I was a Luxembourgian
Burmese, and that
seemed to be enough.
As a mixed race
Asian American, I
took pride in the exoticism
of those lineages.
No one in Washington D.C. Or
anywhere on the planet as far
as I could tell, could boast
of Burmese-Luxembourgian
bloodlines.
But that was it.
I didn't really know much
more about Burmese life
before my family had left.
I didn't really know
much about Henry Wagner
and what had pushed him west.
Instead, in the late
'90s and early 2000s,
as I came into adulthood
and left adolescence,
I took pride in being vaguely
indiscriminately brownish.
And as Jane so eloquently
summarized in her intro--
you did a much better job than
I ever could with my book.
When Time Magazine ran that 1993
magazine cover-- incidentally,
it's amazing how
many people remember
that Time Magazine
cover, right, proclaiming
the new face of America, the
future face, if you will,
the person on the cover looked
equally indiscriminately
brownish, just like me.
So future face was me,
and I was future face.
That would be the
posture I adopted
for much of my late adolescence
and early adulthood.
I was indiscriminately brown
and was that not fantastic?
The not knowingness of it all.
I was like some
kind of exotic bird
that had flown in
from overseas--
a toucan in Washington D.C.,
a flamingo in New York City.
But
As as grew up, and
as I grew older,
and as circumstances and
politics around me changed,
this not knowing and this
embrace of the general
gave way to a desire
for the specific,
for a tribe, for
a place to belong,
a feeling of
loneliness that wasn't
going to be satisfied with
friendship or collegiality.
I wanted to know
who my people were.
And I think a lot
of Americans want
to know who their
people are, which
is why we are seeing a boom in
the ancestor search industry
to the tune of $1 billion.
My book is about a
quest to find my people.
I won't give away the endings,
because really the mystery
is what's going to
sell you guys on it.
But basically I
interviewed family members,
from whom I'd been
estranged in many cases.
I unraveled a series
of family mysteries.
I traveled back to
ancestral homelands
and got very familiar with
Esch-Sur-Alzette and Rangoon,
Burma.
I went on several
wild goose chases.
I took many, many
DNA-based ancestry tests.
I had family members take many,
many ancestry-based DNA tests.
I spoke with
Luxembourgian genealogists
and Burmese archivists, and
I pissed a lot of people
off in the process.
Really what I found
is that much of what
we've been telling
ourselves about who we are,
and who we were, are lies.
And that the construct
of one's people
is not really what
we think it is.
I embarked on this
voyage not solely
to get at the truth
of who my family was,
but also to better understand
the immigrant story,
to unpack that well-worn
narrative of coming to America.
Coming to America, not as
in the Eddie Murphy story,
although I suppose that movie
is also relevant to this.
The idea of leaving one place
and starting a new in another
is mostly recounted using
a very gauzy filter.
That the Old World
was left behind
and the New World beckoned us
with freedom and opportunity.
But in reality, immigration
is hard and it is complicated
and it is full of
terrible, terrible choices,
and broken hearts.
And in reality, the place that
we left behind, very often
has quite a bit in common with
the place where we arrived.
Today there is a furious debate
in the public sphere over who
is American and who is not.
Blood and soil
nationalism is resurgent.
So what better time to
re-examine one's own blood
and step foot on one's own
soil, and examine the stories
we have spun for decades,
if not centuries,
about what makes us decidedly
American and of this place.
That's my book.
[APPLAUSE]
- OK.
So we'll do some questions,
and then we'll get to you guys
as quickly as possible.
But I wanted to ask--
because I would never think
about writing about my family.
I write about other
people's families--
people dead long ago.
Susan, I understand you
said that you felt that you
had to write this story.
Why did you have to
write this story?
And I'll ask the
other people as well.
Did you feel that you had
to write your stories?
You can go first.
- Can you hear me?
- What would have happened
if you didn't do it?
- Well, you know, I
tried many years not to.
I kept going over to Hungary,
doing this sort of half,
I wouldn't say charade, but
I had all of my notebooks
and tapes and was going through
the show of interviewing
my father for this book
that she wanted me to write.
But for many years, it was
about our reconnection.
And that the way we could--
really the only way
we could reconnect
was through my interviewing her.
And we, over time sort of
developed a relationship
that we hadn't had in more
than a quarter century.
So for a long time I thought
that's what I was just
sort of working out,
reconciling to the degree one
ever reconciles with one's
parents, through this process.
But at the same time,
I could see how,
to be writing as a
feminist in this era,
and particularly as,
thankfully, trans questions
came to the mainstream,
that I needed
to grapple with
that in my own life,
and not sort of quarantine
it away from my public self.
And so I took the
step of going out.
I mean, it was
uncomfortable for me
because I'm not somebody
who writes personally.
But it was greatly
liberating in many ways.
- I'll just say that--
so I have to do a TV show.
I get to do a TV show
every week, not have to.
And I just had my first child.
And I cannot tell you how
incredibly uncomfortable it
made me, being
pregnant on television,
and being sort of forced to
acknowledge this amazing thing
that was happening.
But to talk about it
and acknowledge it
in any kind of public way
made me really uncomfortable.
So I'm dealing with
that at the same time
that I'm working
on this book that
is exposing deep family
secrets and all kinds
of transgressions.
And at a certain point,
I thought, my god, Alex,
if you have a hard time talking
about being pregnant on TV, how
the F are you going
to deal with the fact
that this book is
going to come out
and everybody's going
to think and understand
very intimate details
about your family.
And I guess one of the ways
I sort of overcame that
or I've rationalized that--
the book isn't out yet, right--
It's coming out in April of next
year, is, all of the stories
and the transgressions and the
sins, if you will of my family,
dovetail with national sins.
And in many ways every
story is discrete, right,
but there are lessons
in all of this
that apply to the current
political climate,
and the ways in which we
think about our sense of place
and our sense of country.
And I think in that way
it felt like, OK, it's
going to be painful when
Aunt Kathy calls me and says,
this is bullshit.
But at the same time,
it's good for us and it's
good for the conversation
to be talking about this.
- Did they know what
you were going to say?
I mean, are there are sort of
things that they figured you
would have to cover
and say don't--
- The legal department
at Random House
has been very thorough
about me going over the more
controversial parts.
I think I'm fair in the end.
It's tough to write about
people who are still alive,
mostly because everybody
has an idea about how
they want to be written about.
Right?
But I think I'm fair, and I
went through the more difficult
passages with those
who are still alive.
My father actually passed away
before the book was finished.
But for those who
are still alive,
I think they'll be OK with it.
Like I said, the book is not
out yet, so the full fallout,
we'll see in the
spring of next year.
- Well, you know, I
would say that for me,
once my father told me a kind of
sanitized version of the family
scandal--
and keep in mind, I was
middle-aged by that point.
I was in my early 40s.
So this had been a
deeply hidden secret.
Once that happened--
I mean, I kind of
had a stew of
emotions about that.
I mean, I found it
fascinating, but I was also
kind of angry about the
fact that they somehow
imagined I was so fragile
emotionally that they had--
I mean, that's the way that--
I'm not sure if that's
true, but that's
the way that I internalized
it or absorbed it.
- Do you think they could
of been embarrassed?
- Oh, yes.
- It's about fragility.
I mean, not just--
- I mean, this was my
initial reaction-- began,
as I researched it, I began to
think that they really imagined
that they were being protective.
And I think that they
were embarrassed.
I mean, keep in mind
that my parents grew up
at a point in time when there
were these eugenicist ideas
out there.
And my mother only
told me that she
was Irish in the final
days at her nursing home.
I said, what?
You're what?
What?
She said, yes, well it wasn't
a good thing to be dear,
then in Colorado Springs,
you know, in the 1910s.
Yeah, that was something.
So that I would say that for
me, why I felt driven to write
it had actually more to do
with the intellectual challenge
of it.
I had a story that was a great
story to entertain people
with at dinner parties.
You know.
I had this philanderer
grandfather.
He was an embezzler.
His life did not
come to a good end.
I want you to buy
the book, so I'm not
going to tell you what happened.
- Did you know him?
- No.
No, no, no.
I did not know my grandparents.
- Do you think you could
of done this if you did?
- Well, that's a very
interesting question.
And I think it would have been
a much harder book to write.
Even as it was, I
mean, it could be--
when I saw my grandfather's
final letter that he ever
wrote to his wife, to
my grandmother, that
was very affecting.
And even some of the telegrams
that passed between them,
because they tended to
communicate via telegram,
which is its own story.
I can remember a conversation
with my agent who said, well,
Alice, telegrams, hmm.
Kind of hard to write a
book around telegrams.
It turns out not to
be true actually.
But what I really
wanted to do was to--
I think it was
Liz-- it was either
Liz or Jane who talked
about opening up
new vistas onto US history.
And, you know, the first
few drafts of this book
were pretty crappy.
And my agent didn't like
it, and some of my friends
didn't even like it.
One of them is here
in the audience.
And so my task became, OK, what
are the bigger stories here?
I knew that there was
something in his story,
and in my grandparents
story that
would allow me to re-narrate
key parts of American history.
And that's what I wanted to do.
And damn it, was going
to do it if it killed me.
- Gail?
- Well actually, I wrote the
book, all three of my books
because I'm really in love
with American history,
probably because of
professor Schlesinger's A,
but also because my
grandfather's trunk.
In this there was a letter
from Benjamin Harrison
to my great grandfather.
I'm like, Benjamin Harrison.
There were telegrams for my
grandfather going to the fight
to see Jack--
anyway.
Great prizefighters.
And going on July 4th, 1929
going somewhere, going to
speakeasies.
There was a speakeasy card
that said, to Mr. Teddy Horne,
when does this expire?
Never.
And I thought, this
is really very, very--
I mean, I don't know this stuff,
and I think it's interesting.
So I wrote my book because I
thought it was interesting.
It was certainly
interesting to me.
- A part of American
history as well.
- Yes.
- I think we should go to
questions from you guys.
And remember to say who you are.
- Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much
for this great panel.
I'm Lauren Williams.
I'm a fellow here at the Nieman
Foundation for Journalism
and I'm an editor at Essence
Magazine in New York.
And I have two questions.
The first is for Alice, and
it touches on the question
that you sort of
ended with about why
we are so forgiving
of capitalism,
and so not of
systemic inequality.
And it's something that my
fellow journalists and I
talk about all the time,
especially in the Trump era.
Why this poor white Midwesterner
sees more in common with Trump
than they do with the poor
black Midwesterner in this phase
of economic anxiety.
And I think black
journalists feel like there's
a little more nuance there.
There's something else going on.
So I just want to know
if you, in your work,
found any sort of
answers to that question?
- Well, it's really
fascinating--
I mean, it is I think one of
the central areas for scholars
to be to be working in.
What I found when I was doing
research on the depression,
and I was looking at
letters that people wrote,
particularly to the
governor of Colorado, who
was a Democrat, but
not a New Dealer--
a guy named Big Ed Johnson.
I mean, I was shocked by
the amount of resentment,
the politics of resentment,
that were directed
towards other white
people actually mostly,
who were on relief.
And I think that in the
Depression years, some
of that initial
sort of antagonism
towards the government
that was really
a pretty sizable movement,
this anti-tax movement
in the late '20s and
early '30s, which
eventually sort of subsides.
And it subsides because more
and more white working people--
and whites more
generally are benefiting
from New Deal programs.
Right.
And so that kind
of initial feeling
that there are these people
feeding at the public trough
that need to be
gotten rid of-- they
need to be eliminated
from the rolls.
You know, this tax
payers league in Colorado
actually opposed
the old age pension.
Right.
I mean they were really
punitive towards other people,
and towards their neighbors.
It was quite shocking to me.
But I think, again,
the New Deal sort of
wins them over for a period of
time until it gets to the point
where the welfare
rolls begin to shift
and it begins to be, it's
not the case that, oh, well--
there's the whole
rhetoric of welfare queens
that you begin to find
in the '60s and the '70s
and beyond, and
especially under Reagan.
Right.
I think during this
period of time, relief,
government programs come to
be understood as racialized,
and self-reliance comes to be
even more understood as white.
That's the best I can do
off the cuff right here.
But I think it's a
central, central question
that we need to be grappling
with and thank you for asking.
- Yeah, of course.
- Just really quickly, my second
question is for Ms. Buckley,
and then also you, Annette.
The work that you guys do
in sort of unearthing truth
about American
history, specifically
about black Jeffersons and
black Calhouns, I'm sure
has been met with much
pushback from other scholars
and historians who don't
want these stories to be real
or to be in the public sphere.
So I just wanted to know
how that resistance informs
the work you do--
this sort of pushback you
get about the legitimacy
of these stories, if you
could talk about that at all?
- I never got any pushback back.
In fact, the amazing thing to me
was meeting the white Calhouns
in Atlanta, who said, yes,
of course, we're all related.
You know what so and so and so.
So I thought, OK.
They accepted it.
They probably would not
have accepted it in 1888,
but they accepted it in
2016, and were quite pleased
about it.
- Well, I mean, I got a little
bit of pushback from people.
- Yeah.
- But, I mean-- no.
I mean, people write
to other people.
They never write to me.
No, seriously,
that's what it is.
I mean, people write to people
about me, not to me directly.
So I got pushback, but
that sort of went away
as much when Monticello and
the Thomas Jefferson Foundation
sort of got on board with it.
But people still
write, you know,
Annette Gordon-Reed
is the devil books,
but they don't write
directly to me about it.
- My name is Susanna Grannis,
and I graduated from Radcliffe
58 years ago.
And I haven't been back.
I must have been back,
but I don't remember it.
And I was so pleased to
walk into the Radcliffe Yard
and see that it was the same.
That's really wonderful.
I'm here because there
is a family secret that
has been uncovered
in our family,
oddly enough all
these years later
by three grandchildren
of my grandfather
named Armfield
Franklin VanBibber--
a very unfortunate name,
because Franklin and Armfield
were leading slave
traders between Alexandria
and Louisiana for many years.
They became very wealthy.
So we're going into it.
We went to a little
museum in September
that was the slave pens of the
Armfield office in Alexandria.
So my question is
seeking advice.
I'm reading about this,
I'm learning about this.
My brother is as well.
And we are so obsessed.
But where do we go?
Where do you go with this
information about your family
and what people in your family
have done that is so horrible?
What does one do with
something like that?
So anybody who would like to
answer, I would appreciate it.
Thank you.
- Well, that's a tough one.
Share it with the
rest of your family.
Share it with your friends.
You can become involved
in organizations
that are trying to
improve the community--
things for recompense in a
way to take to pay it forward
in a way.
I think it would be enough--
a good beginning, the fact
that you're grappling with it
yourself, and you're
being honest with it.
Because there are so
many people who wouldn't
be involved with it at all.
So that's a step in
the right direction.
Do other people have other
ideas other than making
it a part of your family's
story, and making sure
that other people
know about it as well?
You might write
something about it?
Joshua Rothman is a
young historian who
has been writing about this--
- [INAUDIBLE]
- Yeah.
Yeah, that's what I'm saying.
Yeah, he's been
writing about this.
Get in touch with him.
I mean, there are
all kinds-- what
had happened with the
Jefferson thing is
that members of the family have
been together different places
and they have gone and
spoken about what this means.
And they sort of grappled
with it very publicly.
I don't know if you're a
public person in that way,
but that's one way that those
descendants have dealt with it.
- I would just second
the idea that you
have to weave the truth
into the family narrative
and keep handing it forward
into future generations.
And the thing that I
found at the end of this
is, finding your
people in the past
is a really tricky concept,
because the community that we
have in the present
is really the tribe
that we should be focused on.
And I think too often and
we look backwards instead
of looking around us, especially
in this particular moment
in time.
Reinforcing the threads
of community or kind
of the urgent task at hand.
- Next.
- Hi.
My name's Edward Ball.
I'm a write.
I wrote some five books that
each has a family history
strands.
Probably the one that's better
known than the others is
called, Slaves in the Family.
- Oh yeah.
- Which I'll get to in a moment.
But family history used to be
a form of public relations.
It was the idiots
genre of storytelling
and of historiography.
Fortunately it's no longer that.
And our panel is
good evidence of it.
It seems to me to involve--
my experience is that
doing family history
involves a degree
of psychoanalysis,
not only psychoanalysis
on one's subjects
but psychoanalysis
on one's self.
And in analysis one
uncovers motives in oneself
such as exhibitionism,
aggression,
and other uncomfortable
pieces of one's identity.
I wonder if some
of the panelists
have considered this
analogy of their project
to a form of psychoanalysis?
What one does is look at
symptoms in one's own family--
places of conflict and
trauma and picks at them.
That's one thing I
wanted to observe.
But about the last speaker,
the last questioner
who talked about being descended
from the slave trading firm
run by Isaac Franklin
during the mid-19th century.
Franklin and Armfield,
I would suggest
trying to tell that
story in a public way.
There is a cathartic
and important--
this probably gets
us back to analysis.
There is an effect of
catharsis and relief
in telling stories of
historical trauma and injury
in a public way.
- OK.
OK.
- For those who are
here and also for those
to tell those stories.
- Yeah.
- Anybody want to go?
- Oh I just wanted
to say that I think
I would be fascinated
to read the story,
because I don't know about it.
I don't know about these people.
Because when I was
in Charleston, just
for no other reason, the big
tourist place is the slave--
this is the slave market.
Come and see the slave market.
So I would love to
read about your family.
And I think you don't
need to apologize.
You do need to apologize,
but it's not you that did it.
So it would be interesting.
- Anyone want to talk
about psychoanalysis?
- Oh, well.
[LAUGHTER]
- All right, I'll go.
- You'll go and then
one more question.
- To psychoanalysis that is.
Yeah, you know, there
are many-- well,
I was going to say there
are many times I felt
I needed to be in
intensive therapy
to get through
this book project.
I think I was also a
therapist for my father, who
was utterly opposed to any form
of psychoanalysis or psychology
or counseling, unfortunately.
And to get approval to have
gender reassignment surgery,
she needed two letters from
mental health professionals.
And she went and saw two
different people once,
and she tossed aside
the one letter that
said that they thought she
had troubles with identity
more generally, but
after one session
she couldn't say for
sure that it was gender.
And the other psychologist
didn't actually
write a letter till later.
So my father then went
out and made up a letter
from a friend--
a female friend and wrote it
in this sort of feathery font,
thinking that that would
make it look more authentic
or something and sent it off
to the surgeon from my father's
email account.
And the surgeon went
ahead and said, fine.
So the surgeon I had an
interesting conversation
about that later.
Although, as it
turns out, you know,
my father never
regretted the surgery
and it was one of the
few things that she
was happy with until
the day she died.
So this is not actually an
indictment of the surgeon,
although--
Well, I'll leave it at that.
Incidentally, Susan, you, at the
end of your remarks noted that
some of the common
threads-- a strong man--
if we're talking about strong
men faking medical letters,
I seem to remember
a moment last year
where we were treated to Donald
Trump's personal physician's
letter.
Just putting that out there.
[LAUGHTER]
I'm just saying.
Yeah.
- Not saying, just saying.
- OK.
I think we have--
yeah, go ahead.
- Oh, I'm Rayshauna Gray.
I coordinate the
gender initiative
over at the business school,
and I'm a historical researcher
at Tufts.
So I'm writing the story
of the last two centuries
of my family's history
through the lives of my six
direct female ancestors, or the
six most recent ones and then
me.
And it feels overwhelming.
And I'm, of course, unearthing
a whole bunch of unfortunate,
tense topics like enslavement,
like failed Reconstruction
and the like.
How did you all know that you
did your ancestor's justice
when you wrote about them?
And if you did,
how did you know?
Were you even aiming for it?
- This is an
interesting question.
Thank you.
I mean, I heard from
another historian recently,
a labor historian,
Nelson Lichtenstein,
who really loved the book.
And he said to me
in this email, I
wish I had been able
to do for my forebears
what you've done for yours.
And I wrote him back
and said, well, I'm
not sure that that's the way
that they would feel, however.
And I guess that for me--
mine is a very different story.
Right?
I mean, I'm exposing
something that my grandfather
did that was venal.
And so perhaps my
response to your question
would be very different from
that of other panelists.
But I never saw it as
doing them justice.
That was never my goal.
I wanted to be fair.
And I struggled with that.
I struggled with, am
I hyper-correcting her
because of what I've
read about my grandfather
and maybe I should
be more sympathetic?
Or am I being too sympathetic
towards the women?
Because I had more evidence
of their suffering.
But doing justice doesn't
quite capture what I was up to.
I really wanted to--
as I said, it was about
re-narrating American history.
- Also, our ancestors
have been doing themselves
justice for a long time.
So maybe it's our job
to hold their feet
to the fire a little bit.
Don't worry too much
about it is my advice.
- Thank you.
- With my extended
family, they were glad
that someone was
pulling together
the threads of family history.
And were actually
glad that I was
trying to figure out this
incredible enigma of my father.
So I had a fair
amount of support
from my father's
extended family.
- Hi, I'm Caroline.
I'm a public history
graduate student.
And there's actually
several of us here.
So I'm thinking
about in the spaces
that we tell stories
about American history
that tend to be more simplified
or tell a linear narrative--
you know, museums, textbooks,
really the public history--
venue.
Obviously all of your
stories complicate
these, the narratives that we've
been telling about the past.
So do you have any vision
for what can be done?
Or what does this mean for
how we talk about the past,
say like, within an exhibit
panel or places where you
can't tell a book length story?
- I'll just say really quickly,
one of the ways I feel like
the past can help change the
narrative is by re-examining
current events in
a different light.
So for example in Burma
there's a mass ethnic cleansing
being undertaken in
part of the country.
The Rohingya are a marginalized
ethnic tribe in Burma.
And the current
military government
has waged a very
bloody campaign.
463,000 of them have fled
to nearby Bangladesh.
And everyone sort of
looks at this moment
and says, well, how is it that
a Buddhist nation is killing
its own, throwing babies
into fires, displacing
hundreds and thousands of
innocent men and women?
And the truth is--
and I discovered this
in my research--
Burmese Buddhist nationalism
has been a scourge on Burmese
society for over 100 years.
And it's part of my
family's own story,
and it dovetails with the
history of the nation.
And I think once you have
that information about Burmese
nationalism and the fact that
its roots stretch back much
further than we think,
one can re-examine
what's happening in the
country in the present day,
and almost sort
of rewrite history
to be more accurate
in real time.
That's a discrete
example, but I think
that's one of the ways in
which the past and the present
interconnect.
- Well, thank you very
much, the panelists.
With that, we will wrap up.
Thank you guys for coming.
[APPLAUSE]